Hello Freak bitches. Yeah.
Most people think Oj did.
It does a few people that think
like I heard the crazy ones like,
oh j son did or something
like that. I'm like, what?
I'm so balls deep in the Oj
stuff. Anything he does, I
watch it. But like I said,
my brother went, God, I Went, God,
I wish I really knew the truth about
o j and j. My brother looks me goes,
are you shitting me? Like,
we all know the truth, man.
But people put all these different
stories out there where you're like, God,
maybe you didn't do it, but I just want
to know for a fact like that. Like what?
How did it really go down? Do you think
he's ever going to come out and be like,
listen, no, no, I don't think he did.
I don't think he necessarily
remembers anymore.
You think he was just in a frenzy?
I think it's entirely possible that he's
a sociopath and a narcissist with brain
trauma from trauma.
And I think that a lot
of times narcissists and
sociopaths like to that degree,
like he's just charming the world.
Hey, I'm Oj Simpson. I'm a good guy.
I've always been a good guy.
Basically they have a conflict free life.
Yo Ass want to go be with my family.
Got sounds like a man.
He's got a weird thing going on man.
Like he's trying to paint this image
all day long of him being a good guy.
Me while he's got these demons and
knows dad was gay and they say it.
That's why you beat like a lot
like you so upset about that. See,
I don't trust that guy. But
when he gave that, uh, anyone,
he's like snapped at the judge.
Yeah,
it was super weird and you definitely
shouldn't do that when you're trying to
get what he'd snap on. I got upset
about something that I'm on something.
He's like, I said I wasn't
there or something like,
yeah, yeah. I forget what it,
what it was like the Las Vegas Room
definitely didn't handle it well. Who?
Look man, when you're a man and you're
locked up with other men, you know,
as prisoners all day long forever.
It's just,
it's a horrific existence.
It's amazing that he was able to get
through it at all and then still pull off
that kind of charm and not
can only suicide. Yeah.
They said he was killing it in there.
Like he was the prime example of a,
of a prisoner and it was like he started
organizing church groups and like
feeding everyone's lunches
and like, he was cool. Wow.
Well find meaning in that shit.
I wonder if you'd like,
has like a deep what's going
on? He's Chloe's dad. Yeah.
A lot of people think he's closed.
That get the fuck out of here. What?
Chloe's not half black. Uh, well
they just don't love black guys.
They is that what it is? Hmm.
Some people do well and you know,
Oj was super close with strong
rumour Kardashians. Strong rumor.
That strong room. No one would
be surprised. Uh, I would,
well, my point was like, what
kind of memory of the event? Okay.
We both agree he did it right. So if he
did it, what kind of memory does he have?
Do you remember sticking
the knife in them? You'll
remember that traumatic event.
I wonder,
I wonder if you're a sociopath and I
wonder if you've been telling people for
all these years that you're innocent.
I'm all you remap trying
to find the real killer.
I'm trying to get out of
it upon the real killer.
Everyone's all and not once did
he bring up the real killer.
I'm trying to find my wife's
killer. The reason why, I mean,
he never said that during any of the
parole thing when he can't want it to get
out. Oh No, not on my wife's killer. Yeah.
Never on this. Someone killed my wife.
That ship's sailed was time me.
I'm being tried for it.
I'm being unjustly accused.
He just say the case that I lost,
he came out with a book. If I
did it. Yeah, he was going to,
but he didn't release that book.
I thought he did none.
All the proceeds went to the,
the gold. No. Um, I believe,
I'm pretty sure that the
publishing company backed
out of that private smart on
their part.
Yeah.
You can't do that while you
have them on the podcast.
Oh,
I don't know if he would do it, but
if he did do it. Yeah, I have them on.
Yeah. Right yet have to
have mine. I did it shit up.
IDF is right. It's hidden right there.
Remember that's what they had did.
Oh that's right.
If I did it in the eye and
on Amazon by j Simpson.
Jesus Christ. That's, that's still,
I thought they pulled that
confessions of the killer in all caps.
Goldman and Kim Goldman.
Nick. That's how it happened.
They had to they're they're getting
money. Yeah. They get all the money,
all the money.
But in did he really right the full
story or are the rights to them?
Yeah,
because double jeopardy right
off the crime is sorta what it is.
How much money do,
and also they have a
civil case against him.
How much money do you think
he made off that book?
Cause you don't make that much money
off books unless you're just fucking,
you do feel like Bill O'reilly,
j k Rollins or some shit. Yeah.
If you're writing books like old
people read, they buy a lot of books.
If I did it and we kind of know how
you'd do it. If he did it. Is it,
I need to read the knife. Stab both of
them go to Chicago, called the lawyers,
come back, come back, act dumb.
Kardashian helps me out. Rinse,
repeat. Does it say how many books?
So many books they sold.
I got to think it was not much.
I don't even know it was
out and I'm all about this.
He got some sort of crazy settlement.
Right?
It was like $35 million settlement
or something like that. 33 million.
But how much has he been paid?
I used to know is um, um,
Ron Goldman sister. Really?
Yeah. What do you, how'd you know her?
She worked on something that I did for,
she was very nice,
very cool check.
Brian ran into the dad in
Phoenix selling men's shirts.
Like what's the big paws ans I was
trying to think what his selling,
but I remember seeing like
men's golf shirts or some shit.
Like the struggle is real for Ron
Goldman, you know, like game over,
you lose a child and it
goes down like that. Just,
just hard believe that that guy's
now going to get out. What do you do?
I mean you only got certain amount
of time left on this planet. I,
I'd probably get a hand
probably hammer beat.
It's going to be tough to get Oj still
pretty athletic and black. So I would,
I'd probably get a gun
and when he gets out,
drive down to Florida or if he comes
back to Brentwood skin to make it super
easy on you and probably shoot him,
could be headed to reality
TV. When I called, Oh mine
watching that documentary
about him completely.
I completely forgot about all the weird
stuff he was doing before he did go to
jail. Just show in Vegas where he
had, I didn't even know about it.
Seeing it on the documentary shows
everything I had to wrap. Yeah,
you gotta Wrap Saran wrap.
So after he murdered his wife,
right before he went to
jail and like 2005 or six,
um,
innocence to the gross
is innocent.
Are we going to get pulled off of Youtube
for the Oj Simpson away? Look at this.
Oh my God. Wait a minute. We got to play
this. Let's, let's ride. Let's ride this.
Give us some fine.
Oh my God.
These girls
have titties out.
This is real.
This is a real music video.
America's most wanted.
This is crazy. He's dressed like
Elvis. I can't believe this is real.
Oh
look, those steady gimme some volume
here. People hear this, right?
People on Youtube are Hannah's.
No. Oh, it will get taken down.
Probably not for you.
Play just the audio way.
Oj Simpson get juiced.
What year did this happen?
Like 2004.
this is insane.
This is insane. It's all these
girls taking their pants off.
So he was doing a prank show and you
got juice was the tag line. Oh my God.
He did it. He did a fucking prank
show after he murdered two people.
He's got a midget on his lap. This
is insane. I can't believe it.
I've seen this. Oh my God.
All you player haters.
Yeah.
Get on your knees and get some of these,
grabbed his crotch.
He said these nuts.
This is crazy.
And you got to think,
is this 2005 is that what you said?
So he's gotta be like 60 years
old when this is happening. Damn.
It only has 15,000
views on youtube and check
in in a couple of days.
We just helped the Jews don't
think people knew about it,
but another reason he needs to come on
the God damn podcast. Yeah. Maybe to him.
Come on dressed like Elvis again. No, no.
Maybe would come on justice white face.
God Damn, this is nuts.
He's a terrible divorce.
I wonder if he was like, look, I really,
I make money and so on through this idea
of him. Look at him with a do rag him.
Yeah. Don't piss them
off though. Very strange.
You did a Bingo at like a white
face with like a security.
Oh my God.
The struggle is real.
This is so strange.
I can't believe this.
This rap song where it's like it's hot
in the streets in La. That is true.
Yeah. He was like a legit wrap flung
though. This is the remix, Jamie.
It's got a good point.
Both of them are good.
We don't need to watch anything on a
terrible person. I wonder what he's,
I mean, I feel like a guy like that
probably like would do anything.
It's like this is good.
We've got to figure out some way to do
and who's going to be working with them?
You're not going to get like the top minds
of Hollywood. Fuck no, no one's, I mean,
he might pop up on some reality show,
but dude, a matching knows hoes.
They were saying he was getting more
women than ever when he got out,
like when he was out of trial,
they still went to Florida,
was just Dick and girls down now,
like recently
killing it.
What ties got out?
What type of site
cool
chicks are hooking up with Oj right now.
Skanks
[inaudible].